(electronic music)
(rock music)
- Coch Brothers, you're really
making it difficult for me
to boycott you, alright?
They can't possibly
make anything else
that's an integral part
of my every day life.
Lycra?
(audience laughing)
The world's most
comfortable fabric?
(audience laughing)
Okay, we have to go figure
this out because nobody
is taking my lycra.
(audience laughing)
- I think there's
always this stuff,
the Illuminati, people
are controlling the world.
No, it's two old white
dudes and they're brothers.
(laughing)
You can see them.
And it's, they're
not underground,
they're near Palm Springs, man.
- You both get offered a gig
opening for the Coch Brothers.
(audience laughing)
And it pays a lot of money.
And don't even try to tell
me you're not gonna do it,
cause every comic
has a price, alright.
So I know you're gonna do it.
- Yes!
- I'm just gonna
throw out numbers.
- You don't have to finish that.
- Okay, $1,000.
- No.
- $1,000, no.
- [Larry] $10,000?
- [Hari] No.
- [Larry] $100,000?
You're thinking about it.
- I'm thinking
about $10,000, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- You're thinking about $10,000?
Hey America, Larry Wilmore here.
If you like the Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook, too.
Just don't poke me.
I do not like being poked.
You can candy crush me.